well holy smoke is this ain't no jokers
welcome in
it's the iced coffee hour and uh yeah i
made it over
i am a neighbor next door and i made it
over i walked over and i said hey let's
do a podcast they said hey let's do a
podcast and these guys they have an
awesome channel and i'm here
to talk about whatever these gentlemen
want to talk about stocks the market
finances whatever you guys want to talk
about i guess we can talk about it
what's going on guys we want to talk
about everything stock market related
okay so we want to know what beginners
could do to invest in the stock market
if they have nothing how they could get
their first ten thousand dollars
how they could then make a hundred
dollars a day in the stock market
we want to know the top five stocks
you're buying this year
and how your investing strategy has
changed okay so we got a lot to cover
today that ain't no joke
that's a holy smoke cause wow we got a
lot to get into gentlemen
oh my gosh where do we even start well
first of all it's it's cool to be
your neighbor down yes officially it's
the first podcast since we've been
neighbors man and
it's uh awesome we have no neighbors uh
you're my only neighbor so yeah every
all the other houses are getting built
right now but
yeah that house was you know 14 plus
months in the making
so uh to finally move in there is like
uh i don't want to call it a dream come
true but it is nice
so and that's the first i don't say it's
the first house probably the second
house
this is the first house in nevada that
i've really wanted like the
all everywhere else i've lived it's kind
of been like you know um
let's try to go way under budget let's
try to live as affordable as possible
to that house i definitely didn't go
over budget but i did i bawled out a
little bit okay just a little bit with
the with the upgrades and those sorts of
things so
man i love it and this community is
great you got the gym close
jack and i go get jacked all the time
now we're gonna might do sprints after
this podcast is over you never know so
this is awesome it is really fun to be
able to text you and be like hey you
want to do the gym in 15 minutes
i'll see you there and it's like a 50
foot walk
down to the gym community center it's
been a lot of fun yeah yeah last night
text you hey you want to go grab dinner
you're like oh yeah let me see oh yeah
let's go
and yeah yeah that's the type of stuff
that if you live on the other side of
town you know with a friend you can't do
it
you know you got to have it planned out
but this it's like you could do
something last minute so
yeah it's been awesome love it and uh
yeah so we got to talk about your stock
market escapades
now where did this all start because uh
i
i don't think a lot of people know your
your true backstory
working at a as a gas station attendant
yeah
yeah a tendon that's that's a that's a
term there attendant it sounds like i'm
the guy that like pumps it if i think
i think there's still some states where
you can't legally pump that's true
oregon yeah what oregon are you serious
yeah
oregon wow crazy there's a fancy gas
station in beverly hills where they have
this
uh the service for it it's the gas like
a dollar extra a gallon that's a luxury
but you go to oregon and it's just like
assumed someone's gonna
pump your gas yeah do you do you tip
them or is it i mean
i'm assuming that you do that you do tip
them yeah
it's just to provide jobs like that's
the they provided they made lettuce
legislation to like really of course
yeah so you have to have
people pumping your gas for jobs is that
a service people
want yeah for me no i don't think so i
was about to say like
i feel would feel uncomfortable i would
feel like this is something i'm capable
of doing myself
and i should be able to they're probably
better at it than you are
yes so if they can do it better than you
sure from a from a quick google search
people in oregon do not tip oh okay
so it's not customary to tip wow okay
well it doesn't cost any money
right well if it's free yeah and you
don't pay more for gas
where does the money come from listen i
didn't research that far
i just saw that the locals do not tip
yeah because oregon doesn't have sales
tax
that is your like their big thing that's
their shtick no sales tax you buy
something what you pay is what you pay
i'm curious where the money's coming
from no oregon don't they
also have no state income tax no oh
it's not oregon okay i don't know why i
was thinking oregon was wondering
gosh imagine i would be in oregon i
would be in portland right now if
there's no sales tax
income tax jeez everyone would move to
portland
oh my goodness but anyway anyway yeah
back back to the the whole story there
so
in terms of me getting the stock market
actually happened before i i got to gas
station and quick trip that actually
happened back when
i worked at walgreens uh making shoot i
don't know i think i started there at
8.75 an hour
in the photo department at walgreens and
essentially that walgreens had a plan
where essentially you could
buy shares of walgreens stock for
i think it was either a 10 or a 15
market discount so you know if the stock
was trading at let's say 20
a share you could buy it for i don't
know 18 19
a share or whatever and so i was like
well that seems like a no-brainer you
just had the only catch was you had to
hold it for at least three months
and so i was like okay let me start
doing that so i started doing that
that's how i
set up a fidelity account and then i had
an accounting teacher
actually a community college who showed
me the most powerful thing in my life
as far as financially which is a
compounding calculator oh i love that
yes and he would show us you know if you
had this amount of money and you
and you got this percentage return and
you know if you've never
seen that before that is like the most
mind-blowing thing at least for me
seeing that right and uh so right away i
was like okay investing i kind of
started doing the walgreens thing and
then i was like well i can look into
other stocks and i was like this is all
available information on the internet
and then i just started going down the
rabbit hole started watching warren
buffett things
learning all that and next thing you
know i was starting to invest money and
it was like 250
500 bucks a time back then it was 19.95
to buy a stock to execute any trade
yes or sell you don't realize how
good you have it now oh man thank you
robin hood i used to use sk
it was scottrade back some someone
bought them i forget who it was
but it used to be scottrade i think back
then
it was and this is like mid 2000s but
this i think they were like
seven dollars and ninety five cents or
it was like seven to ten bucks
yeah per trade if you wanted to buy
anything or sell anything
yeah fidelity was 1995 when i first got
started and then very shortly after they
switched to 9.95 because i think they
were getting competitive pressure
one time i made a huge mistake and i
phoned in a trade
i didn't know how much it was 39.95
and we're talking i was buying like 400
worth of a stock
so now i need to get a 10 return roughly
just
more than 10 yeah yeah then just to
cover
the trade to buy and then imagine if i
was to sell another 19.95 if i did
online or 39.95
but anyways that's a long story so i i
stayed with it because i at the end of
the day i looked at it and i was like i
think i can get a positive return
then they lowered in 9.95 i got even
more into investing so i'm like oh now
it's only 10
to buy a stock i'm like this is great
and i would save up between five hundred
dollars and a thousand dollars a time
and i go to make that move so the way i
thought about it is i save a thousand to
invest
you know which would sometimes take me a
month if not several months back then
to do that right the way i kind of
thought about it was all right
uh invest a thousand is a ten dollar
trade commission so that's like one
percent
right and then so basically in my mind
i'm like i gotta get at least two
percent on this position
to cover cover the the trades and um
and then i just started building from
there at first it was the most boring
stocks i bought
stocks like canada foods walmart
like like uh i bought bp after the oil
disaster
uh the the stock just got hammered i was
looking at the balance sheet at that
time and i was like i don't think
they're going to go bankrupt there's
some people pricing it for bankruptcy
they made it through i made a little
money on that um and then i just started
building from there when i got the job
at quick trip that's when i really
started rolling
so that was that was a game changer
because then i was making uh
for they started me out about 40k moved
up really quick
uh to a high bonusing store one of the
best bonusing stores in arizona
started making over 50k and um
and then my apartment was probably
725 or 750 a month rent
and uh i used to keep all my other
expenses super low i used to
shut the air conditioning off if i was
gone at work and like do anything
eat ramen noodles and just like i used
to eat those uh
pork and beans uh you guys you can get
those back then you get them for like 88
cents at walmart
and then you throw a piece of ham or two
in it throw it in the microwave that
would be a meal
less than a dollar so i try to keep all
my meals less than two dollars for sure
but ideally less than a dollar
and uh man i was just investing i was
invest in beast
and uh invest in like a thousand two you
know
at that time you know when i started
getting to a place where i could invest
like
two thousand dollars a month it was
crazy that's a decent amount of money
though two thousand a month
so what were you making to invest two
thousand a month back then
that's when i got up that's when i uh
what was i making
as terms of my job yeah so that's when i
got bumped up to making
about four thousand to five thousand
dollars a month
for my job and then you get the taxes
taken out of that
you know uh quick trip uh they used to
help a lot with health and health
insurance
so you got the health insurance you had
some other cost uh i used to
always keep my expense super low as far
as my cars went
things like that so yeah i was able to
start investing like two thousand
dollars a month
um back then which yeah it felt like a
lot of money there's no doubt about it
and
and that's how i really started this
snowball rolling in 2010
and then i also simultaneously taken my
investing game up to
another level and i found some really
good stocks back then so
what did you find you know what i
realized alex
that you're wearing two different kinds
of socks yes but you know what else
oh what we could just sponsor ourselves
in this video how about that you know
what that sounds great i always like
my own posts anyway me too and for a
limited time if you want access to the
youtube creator academy where i go over
exactly what you need to do step by step
to start a youtube channel and turn it
into a business
i will give you 200 off when you use the
coupon code
200 off the link is down below in the
description this is everything that i
have learned about how to grow a youtube
channel what makes a successful title
and thumbnail
everything you need to do along the way
it's all down below in the description
and
it's 200 off 200 bucks off 200
off but i'm gonna take you up on that
deal because i have this to family to
run
wow there we go well thank you guys so
much for watching enjoy the discount and
with that said let's get back to the
video
some tattooed chef oh yeah that's now
yeah
so yeah oh gosh no so
there was a a stock i found named
trinity industries
and uh this is when i started piecing
things together as far as
uh trends that were multi-year trends
that were going to play out
in industries where i saw a tremendous
opportunity so trinity industries was
this company
super boring company they they had a
construction side of their business
uh selling like safety cones and like
the the stuff that's like on the side of
the highway
that if you like hit it it kind of like
crumples you know
those sorts of things but they also have
to decide their business
of selling rail cars in this real car
business
there's hardly any um companies that
sell rail cars it's such a random thing
you need to get all these industry
standards there's maybe
two or three companies in the whole
united states that probably are
sell big volumes of rail cars right
specifically
oil oiling gas rail cars well i was
looking
and at that time in north dakota
fracking was starting to take off huge
and you were starting to hear stories
about people were moving to north dakota
making like 120
150 000 like basically just fracking oil
and so i was like well there's no
pipelines to like transport this so the
only way you could transport it is
through rail cars
so i looked at this and i was looking at
the stock and it was trading
very darn cheap and i'm like they're
about to see a massive
multi-year boom in their business in my
opinion sure enough that's exactly what
played out
and trinity industries went on a crazy
run
and that was one of the first if not the
first stock that
really gave me a lot of confidence that
i'm like i can do this
like i can do this before that it was
kind of like
this is this is something i could be
decent at that was the stock that took
me and i was like
i can be really good at this and i gave
me the confidence
and then after that it was a lot more
stocks including cabela's and some
others but the trinity industries that
was huge for my confidence
that was a really good time to invest
though yeah to start in like 2008
nine that was like you missed the entire
run
up started going down and that's when
you started investing so everything
after that was was gravy for the most
part
yeah i just wish i had more money back
then the problem was you know 2008 2009
you know i'm investing 500 bucks a time
or 250 bucks whatever
you know 2010 i finally started getting
going but that was until like the end of
2010
so that huge initial ramp up i had like
hardly any money in the market
so i really wasn't able to capitalize
but from your standpoint
what if i had got in in 2006 maybe that
would have killed my confidence right
off the bat
seeing the market dip i don't know you
know you can't ever go back in time like
that but uh
but yeah it was certainly you know it
was an interesting time to get involved
in the market because
you know a lot of people are scared and
i looked at it i'm like i'm just getting
involved in this thing man like you know
i i didn't have much fear as far as that
went but i also didn't start out like
super confident like oh i'm gonna be
such a great stock picker that happened
over time i needed to see the results
and that's mostly how i am in life
so so you built up the portfolio your
number is 200
000 at 25 years old and then once you
were 25 years old is that when you
quit quick trip no i had 200k before i
was 25 so i quit quick trip at 24
and um
you know it was a it was a tough
decision so
i was really burnt out a quick trip i'll
be completely honest you know
it was um it was a grind man up at 4am
almost every day and um just putting in
the hours you know you're working 48
hours a week sometimes 50 hours a week
on manager's schedule you know waking up
at 4 a.m you get off pretty early you
get off at like
2 30 but you're on your feet
all day there's no breaks a quick trip
there's no yo let's go sit in the back
for 30 minutes aren't
legally you're supposed to have a lunch
and two breaks or do they is it just
you know well um
yeah i'm not gonna throw my whole
company under the bus man
they gave too much to me for me to ever
throw them into the bus but
i don't know you'd have to look into
that situation
but uh essentially yeah there were no
there were no breaks there were no uh
official breaks there was no like oh you
get
you know go clock out now and take your
lunch or
take your 15. at walgreens yeah it was
super professional like that in terms of
like
you know you got your 15 then you got
your 30. and people were super demanding
of it too
quick trip you might work 10 hours
straight you're on your feet your whole
time and you might never get a chance
you if you're gonna even dream of eating
you better eat that hot dog fast that's
all i'm gonna say about that i
i hated the 15 30 minute breaks when i
was doing that uh data entry job
they made you take uh the 15 minute
break in the morning 15 minute break in
the afternoon and i think it was a 30 to
45 minute lunch
i hated it because i didn't
want to have lunch i didn't want to take
a break i was just like i'm just getting
going
and now i have to take a stupid and i'd
literally sit there and just twiddle my
thumbs for 15 minutes being like can i
just finish
what i was working on yeah and i
remember we had uh
roxanne i did not like roxanne she was
the uh
like the back office manager and i would
tell her these complaints like
can i oh what i wanted to do is just
take my break a little bit
later and then push my lunch later like
i want my lunch to be as close to the
end of the day as possible
no no no you can't do that you have to
take your lunch between these hours like
it made
no sense to me and then i brought up the
argument what if i just work straight
and i just get off an
hour and a half early no we can't do
that we have to comply with you it's
just
it's stupid it's because i i'd just
rather work and just get it done
and then leave yeah leave an hour and a
half early then i miss the traffic
driving home but
never understood the the need for
a break i don't know just just take a
break when when you're hungry
yeah and for as long as you need to and
then just come back and finish it that's
what it was like for me working in a
restaurant before i worked for you
it was there was there was no mandatory
breaks even if you were working like an
eight and a half hour shift or whatever
you just take a break whenever you get
hungry or whenever you like get tired
from walking everywhere
then you take like 15 get a sandwich get
back to work yeah
so it should be they should really go
over the entire structure of the nine to
five
i really think they should stagger it
get rid of the nine to five
completely and just have different
shifts like you want to be
shift a b or c and maybe shift a starts
at like
5 a.m for the people who just want to
finish early shift b
starts like eight shift c starts at like
11.
you need to have people in the office at
the same time
well nine to fives are typically those
jobs where like you're going to have a
manager
you're going to have like people above
you it's going to be a corporate
structure
and they need to oversee all the work
that's true yeah i'm just thinking from
traffic
yeah because if we spread out the times
where people start and leave there
wouldn't be so much
rush hour traffic i know
yeah oh gosh anyway yeah yeah so anyways
yeah quick trip it was a grind you know
i remember uh
even as early as you know 2011 so i
hadn't even been working for the company
that
long i remember just like having this
fantasy i'd be driving to 99th and
camelback quick trip i was working at i
had this fantasy there was this
pretty decent nightly nice uh just like
two-story office
it was kind of almost across from the
quick trip i remember driving by that
and i had this fantasy in my head i was
like how nice would it be
to just like wake up in my apartment
when i want
go to that office and have a little
office like
executive office in that building and
just like invest in stocks all day
and this was like a fantasy that i just
like thought about every day and i was
like man that would just be the
life man that would just be so good like
i could only imagine
how happy i would be doing that and um
and so nowadays when i would that i kind
of live in life my own terms
you know you start taking it for granted
like working from home being able to
like
like if i didn't want to record a
youtube video i don't have to like just
i go play with my kids
at the park and sometimes i remember
back to those days a decade ago
and i'm like dang man like it was just a
dream
you know what i mean to like live life
when you want to not have to work when
you have to work because a quick trip
it's like you know you
you got these hours you better work
those hours right um
and so anyways yeah but 2014 i left the
company
and uh i actually thought i could make
it on stocks with only 200k
which is not conducive for my strategy
so my strategy is investing in stocks
for years
right well when you
only have let's say 200k and you still
need money to live
like you still got to rent you still got
that i had a kid coming right the first
born and so
um you know you then you start putting
short-term pressure on yourself
and so for me i started doing a lot of
short-term trading i got into
margin super heavy because then i was
like well i was getting like 30 to 40
consistently year after year so then i
was like why not margin i only have to
pay
six or eight percent or whatever and uh
next thing you know i'm making short
term trades earnings trades
some would go bad i'd lose like 10 000.
and when you lose ten thousand in a day
uh you know and you all got only got
200k to your name
you know it was just uh it went bad
really really fast it was it was
a good decision because i got out of
that i started businesses and i used
some of the stock market money to start
my first business my real estate
marketing business which i started for
probably less than ten thousand dollars
but i pulled that out of the stock
market
and um it was it was nice to be able to
at least make that decision to
not be stuck in that job because i do
definitely feel like if you're in a
if you're in the financial position
where you don't have money you
you're forced to keep doing this job
even if you don't like it
and um it was nice to be able to make
that decision and be like i'm going to
branch out on my own do my own thing i
don't know what it is which i had no
clue what i was gonna do when i left
quick trip i had no clue i knew i was
gonna for sure
keep doing stocks but i didn't know like
i was like i'm gonna probably do
something entrepreneurial but i don't
know what it is
and then i moved out to vegas and and uh
yeah i didn't even know what i was gonna
do so i took over a year off
no i'm talking no work uh just
stocks and that was it and one thing i
want to mention that i don't mention too
often in videos is that we do actually
have a mentorship group down below in
the description
where you could meet with me every other
week and you can also talk to jack
every other week as well we do zoom
calls we talk for about an hour an hour
and a half you could ask me whatever
questions you want it's a really small
group so we have a lot of one-on-one
time so if that's something you're
interested in joining the link is down
below in the description
would that two hundred thousand dollars
go to after that year off because i'm
sure
you're you're a lot i lost seventy five
thousand dollars that year
wow i was gonna joke because like yeah
it went down to eighty but like
wow i i was i go because i started
pushing putting so much short-term
pressure on myself
and so i was started like i started
doing i don't want to say day trading
but i was
trying to get in and out of positions
and time it out and i had so much
time on my hands which i wasn't used to
having time on my hands because
working at quick trip i work like 48
hours a week so the only
stock market time i'd really put in is
um
like researching companies and then
actually executing a trade
but i was busy during the day so i
didn't have time just to sit around and
look at stock prices
then all sudden i have all this time
doing nothing but looking at stock
prices
i'm doing all the short-term crap and
yeah man it went bad
so quickly how did you last a year
wouldn't you realize after like three
months like hey this is
this isn't working out i'm losing money
at first it was going good
at first it was going that's always how
it is yeah at first at first
i um was reaching new records i remember
i was in maui hawaii
accountants hit all-time high if i
recall her right around that time
my wife actually won a trip from quick
trip uh and it was all-inclusive paid
trip
paid everything to maui hawaii and um
i remember being out there and my
account were pretty much at an all-time
high
and then that summer the market turned
and also you know like i said i was just
getting so much short-term crap man and
i was just
i was going against everything that made
me a successful i was going against it
and it just
yeah it went bad fast so um it was a
great
learning thing i would tell you that um
you know
it definitely taught me about risk
reward uh you know going through going
through that time period
and it allowed me to recharge my
batteries that was a big thing because
quick trip
really took a lot of energy out of me
man and i think that's why i've been
able to run
for so many years now without um
taking any substantial break uh i don't
even know if i've taken
a full week off in the last five years
um
i mean the longest trip i probably took
was maybe four or five days
and even those days i still kind of work
and i still feel like i have as much
energy as
as always so um but anywho i think we
got way off the point there but
it's probably because you drink bankroll
coffee now for sale at
bankrollcoffee.com i
i don't know if to the moon coffee sold
out or not i have to check
if to the moon coffee is available it's
going to sell out 100
it's it's we only made a certain number
of bags it's going to sell out but it's
double the caffeine
this is nice that's total coffee
to the moon coffee was to celebrate moon
day and we wanted to make sure we sell
them all
so i i don't have any to the moon but
yeah
beautiful i need to see some of those
bags that sounds amazing
how did you make your money back oh man
it was a grind i think it took me i want
to say it took me about two
years to get back to where i was
and that brought me to a great lesson i
try to preach to everybody now it's not
just about
you know the reward potential but when
you take that step back you have to
climb just to get back it took me about
two years
and um yeah man it was it was a grind it
was um
just investing in trying to build out
the portfolio
as solid as possible after that and
getting back to at least long-term
investments now i still had one bad
investment during that time which was
gopro which was 2016 2017
but i had win resorts and some other
stock set that did really really well
but it was about getting back to the
fundamentals and
you know staying away from earnings
trades and all that stuff because
i got to a point in the stock market
where i started being able to predict
um and i can i can essentially predict a
lot better than analysts can on certain
stocks like what a company's gonna do
revenue wise and eps wise and
substantially better
but the problem is that doesn't mean
that stock's going to go up
so back to the whole situation i was
like well
i'm right a lot more in these analysts
right so i think this company's gonna
beat beat beat
let me invest in it but then the stock
would go down because of maybe guidance
or maybe the ceo said one thing that
rubbed investors the wrong way like you
never know it was always something
and so um staying away from all that
stuff man and just getting back to the
fundamentals
and i mean if you've followed me anytime
in the past years i'm
always talking about stocks from a
multi-year perspective and if i'm ever
thinking about a short-term perspective
it always ends badly for me
and so that's why you when you hear me
talk i'm like well this company i think
they're going to do this over the next
three to five years
they're going to expand their business
revenues blah blah blah so
but yeah so you then started the real
estate marketing business and how much
were you making
how long did you do that and how much
were you making from that did the real
estate marketing business for about
two years and gosh
i i never made a ton of money from that
business i made enough to pay bills and
keep investing
uh by the time i started building that
up it was 2016 i started it
and that was let's see it took me about
six months just to cover our bills
so i think our bills were about i want
to say about 2500 a month at that time
we're living in a three bedroom
apartment only had one kid um
i i think i might have owned the car we
had the nissan versa
outright but i can't 100 remember so it
took me about six months to get to a
point where making more than 2 500 a
month
and then kept building it from there
2017 youtube started pick up
plus the real estate marketing business
was now popping because in that business
it's all about getting
consistent clients so getting your foot
in the door because then you know
real estate agents keep bringing you
more and more properties and then oh i
need your own photos for this i need um
uh you know a video for this house blah
blah blah so
uh i probably may never made more than
40k from the real estate marketing
company but i only did it for two years
so but by the end of 2017 i already knew
like
youtube was going to be way too big for
me not to focus full-time on that
um and so i actually gave up the real
estate marketing company in january
2018.
and how much did you make from youtube
your first like two three years doing
that
the first year probably less than two
thousand
dollars that was 2016. 2016. yup and i
made
i don't know probably 200 videos that
year yeah 100 200 videos to make
probably less than two thousand dollars
and you'll be getting videos that were
like two minutes long they're like yeah
30 seconds yeah what is a checking
account yes what is a savings account
yeah and i thought about what is a cd
yeah and i thought about quitting
youtube twice along the way
to two different times i thought about
quitting it um
but but anyways uh and then 2017 i
probably made
uh you know probably as much
from youtube as a real estate marketing
company if not more
in 2017 um
shoot i think between the both of them i
might have made
70 or 80 thousand dollars so um
yeah i did really well uh which was
probably my second
best income year i ever had the best
income year i ever had was
i think it was 2013 working at quick
trip i made
like 50 000 or a little over 50 000 from
quick trip and then i made like 39
000 from stocks which
yeah that's another point that gets me
into 2014 that gave me confidence i'm
like oh i made almost as much from
stocks
just stock sales we're not even talking
about ones i didn't cash out on
just stock sales as i made from quick
trip ooh maybe i can keep this going but
anyways you know i don't want to
get up those points again but but yeah
so so going in 2018 man i i knew like
you know if i kept spending time in the
real estate marketing business it was
going to end up
like putting me in a position where you
know it's just like
where's your where's your time best
spent and uh the real estate marketing
business just
it wasn't it wasn't scalable i had to
personally be there um i thought about
hiring somebody but it's not a big
enough margin business
uh especially considering i was
undercutting everybody else's prices in
the market so
yeah i even used to i think i told
graham the story before
um i'd used to drive out to la to take
photos for some agents out in la beverly
hills super high end homes
and i would weigh the like the
photography prices out there is
ridiculous
and i would undercut them all i would
drive out their day
you know do a property or two and then
drive back to vegas same
day yeah but it was it would be
profitable for me because even though i
was
undercutting everybody i was still
making a good sum of money what were you
charging because i remember we used to
pay
depends on the size of the house but
let's say for a four to six thousand
dollar house it was about i think it was
like 600 bucks
was how much we would pay but that also
included
i think a property website if i'm
correct
okay so included a website so you go to
like 90210 beverly hillshome.com or
something like that
yeah so uh yeah i used undercut bad man
uh so if it was under a two thousand
square foot house
ninety nine dollars oh yeah that's
really how do you
how is how do you even make money gas
money man yeah
because i'm thinking with gas well the
time to edit those pictures
cost me 150 to drive one way oh yeah
not enough for la properties for la i
would make like
uh 500 to 600 on a trip for that um
because i would be doing some drone
stuff like drone pictures and stuff and
maybe even some drone videos i think i
was doing for some clients back then
um but um yeah as far as the las vegas i
was 99
for under a 2000 square foot house i was
129 129 dollars for photos if
and this is just if it's from a dslr
right not like drone photos too that was
like an add-on i had
but a 129 for 2000 square feet to
3000 square feet and anything over 3000
square feet was 149
and i would give you 40 50 photos wow
yeah so so i i i definitely undercut the
market man
but i was the worst
you know i took all the pictures with my
iphone no yeah no i'm kidding
no it's just like like you know i i'll
just be honest i was the worst i was the
worst uh
of the bunch like you know some of these
people are really good man
and i undercut st george utah too i
would drive out to st george utah which
is about two hours away
and uh if you don't have the quality the
only thing you have to compete on is
price
so i was the walmart i'm gonna give you
good quality
for cheap price if you want great
quality or you want
top caliber we'll go spend that money
and a lot of real estate agents are very
cheap so you're making 40 000 a year
from your real estate
your marketing company and at the same
time you're making about 40 dollars from
youtube channel the second year you're
doing that yeah
then the third year is when you stop
doing real estate marketing
and you went full like all in on youtube
yeah and how much did you make your
third year on youtube
oh third year on youtube let's see um
boy probably a quarter mil yeah probably
holy cow
youtube scales yeah my first year on
youtube 26
000 second year i think uh
i think it was like 253 260 something
like that
it was the third second year yeah that
was 2018.
okay yeah you made like 250 right it was
about 250 but yeah 2017 because it
started like
late december of 16 full year 2017
26 grand yeah yeah it's crazy man
i remember i used to document the
process back then so
uh on the channel because back then i
was like talk all things finance yeah
you know it wasn't just stocks back then
didn't didn't you post wasn't it every
day that you were posting
yeah i was i treated like it was a daily
vlog essentially
and i would always have something uh to
talk about and yeah it wasn't just
stocks back then and
uh yeah i used to do income updates i i
made
how i make five thousand dollars a month
from youtube or something like that i
would make those sorts of videos
why don't you bring that back why don't
you start doing that well i started
getting a lot of hate as
the numbers grew and i think the last
one i might ever did was maybe like ten
thousand dollars
yeah and um i don't know just you know
uh
the stock market is a different
community and i think a lot of my my
subscribers are different some would
support it but a lot would hate and they
would
uh just not like that i wasn't talking
about stocks they didn't want to
hear about how much money i made and
those sorts of things so
um it's just a different bunch i don't
know you know uh i feel like your
community is really really supportive
for that
and some other communities but yeah this
mine's such a stock market niche that
a lot of them it came across as maybe
like bragging and
just it was rubbing some folks the wrong
way and i was like ah that's all right
so yeah so you continued doing youtube
full-time
built out a few businesses and then when
did you achieve the status of being a
millionaire
was it like 29 28. yeah uh before i was
30 i became a millionaire
and um i actually don't remember the day
i feel like graham and i talked about
this one time because i'm like i'm
having a little deja
vu but we um yeah i hit the number
i think it was close be
between being 28 or 29 i don't remember
specifically if it was like at the back
half of 28 or the beginning of 29 but
yeah i i hit the number and uh you
celebrated if i remember correctly
i didn't feel any different and i didn't
celebrate a million wait oh you
celebrated a hundred thousand
yes yeah yeah i i i
celebrated uh ten thousand i celebrated
i think fifty thousand maybe even
as far as stock market and then i
celebrate a hundred thousand and i i
actually don't remember celebrating a
million dollars becoming eight
we should celebrate your million dollars
man i know
it's too late it's not too late yeah i
know jeez
we could celebrate it's super sushi yeah
cool that would be fun yeah
to jeremy millionaire for many many
years ago yeah but uh
and yeah i felt no different absolutely
no different it wasn't
um i didn't feel some self uh a sense of
accomplishment
and so i guess when they tell you you
know uh
if when you get rich it's like you're
not gonna feel any different
yeah i didn't feel any different there
was nothing there was like the sun
didn't shine different that next day
let's put it that way when my first son
was born the sunshine different that
next day
after hitting a millionaire felt the
exact same
nothing changed so did it feel the same
for you graham
no no and how did you
how did you like the day that you
achieved the status of a billionaire was
it just like equity in a home or
something like that
yeah it was it was mostly property
appreciation yeah and uh i think
like uh cause cause i would track it on
mint so it would just
this estimate would change day to day
but i think i just i closed a commission
or something that kind of like pushed it
over the edge so
but it was mostly because of
appreciating property values that was
like
the bulk of it was just buying a product
yeah yeah i think it was buying a
property and there was some built-in
equity there
and i was able to fix it up and uh
rent it out and then accumulation of
that the value went up
and then yeah uh have you ever disclosed
what the biggest commission check you
ever got in real estate was
oh yeah yeah yeah it was uh selling a
house to orlando bloom
and his i think what did he pay for that
seven
seven or eight million dollars for that
so we made like 100 000. more than that
yeah whoa
yeah that's crazy yeah i mean most
people can't even
fathom that because a hundred thousand
plus from
one deal from one deal yeah and that was
a that was a cool one too because um
like obviously i didn't have a
connection to orlando bloom
but it was from a referral from a client
i met
on craigslist
the guy reached out to me he was a uh uh
i don't want to throw out names here
but he was a uh he was a talent agent
and i think he was working at uh
is either william morris or caa i think
it was william morris uh
and he was living with a roommate and
they
split their rent together they threw in
like 2 500 bucks
and they wanted to rent a house that was
you know somewhat close by their office
and i represented them on that and they
were
awesome to work with because because
they were like younger they were on the
younger side so i think i was probably
like
21 and they were probably late 20s at
the time maybe
early 30s it was just fun to work with
and they were just so nice like really
respectful
and i think we sent like a two year
lease and then after two years they came
back to me wanting to get an even nicer
place so i rented them and
they went from paying like five grand a
month then they went up to like 85 or
like
9 000 a month a few years went by and
then he says my client wants uh
to get a place he didn't tell me who it
was by the way and originally the client
was looking for lease
so he's like my client wants to look for
a lease anywhere from like 20 000
to like 50 000 a month and i was like
yeah
absolutely so i started showing him
around and he didn't tell me who it was
and he's like oh yeah
you know i think this house something
we'll bring him back to
turned out it was orlando bloom but then
once
meeting orlando then talking to him
really turned out that he wanted to buy
something
and um the re he just wanted to rent
long enough
to be able to find a place to buy but
the issue with working a lot of these
leases the clients don't really know
it's like oh you do sales too they're
like oh i just thought you were
a leasing agent i'm like no the whole
point is you know i want to get sales
so it turned out that uh orlando was a
good buyer
and he found a place in uh beverly hills
yeah incredible what a story yeah
that's amazing i always remember
watching millionaire or million dollar
listings los angeles i always loved that
show and
yeah seeing the commissions pop up on
the screen forty seven
thousand two hundred and fifty thousand
it's just like
you know when you see those numbers it's
like from one sale and you know the fact
that
you did six figure deal like that's
crazy you know six figures that came to
you
oh yeah and we bought uh we bought the
guy that referred us
uh breitling a watch wow as a gift yeah
whoa is that that was big because and by
the way he asked for nothing a lot of
these deals
they'll ask like hey if i bring you this
client could you give me you know it
it's common
and this was just he was such a nice guy
he's like i just i just want to make
orlando happy
that's it i don't need anything back but
if if you sell them a house
uh it'll make me look good so that's all
so like is it just a
thank you we got him brightly i can't
remember the exact
yeah i don't want to go too far off
subject here because i know
this is uh kind of more about me but did
you ever have
something like some sort of you know
kind of like me my thing with the real
estate marketing business
how i you know was was undercutting
everybody price-wise did you have some
weird technique or something you did
that you felt most
agents weren't doing that helped you
become a successful
uh in that releases leases that was ed
it was just
just representing tenants when they
found an apartment or a house that was
because no agents would want to do that
but my whole yeah my angle was that uh
that i would help you find a lease and
then hopefully you would
buy a house and so i really learned that
like if someone is spending anywhere
from 4 000 to usually 15 000
a month for for a lease
those people were the ones who ended up
buying something within one to like
three four years afterwards
the people spending under 4 000 a month
never really at least from my experience
never really had the funds to go and buy
something
they were uh they were just they would
perpetually rent
rent rent but after a few years of doing
this i know this wait a second this
price point
they buy something so then i really
honed in uh to
just doing a whole bunch of leases
within that price point how do you
attack that market though like
how do you like i i don't get it like
posting a lot of
rentals up on craigslist um so
what i would do originally what i what i
would do is go to my office i'd identify
and this is called a banker so there's
like no shortage of agents out there
called the banker
but i would identify before you were yes
okay
yeah i would identify uh other agents in
the office who had rentals i just
offered to photograph their places for
free
did that in exchange for me being able
to post it up on craigslist
and they were ecstatic because they get
free photography
and they get more marketing so it
doesn't cost them a single dime
and a lot of these places i would just
rent out so
yeah and you wouldn't make any direct
money on the the rental
would you i would okay a little bit now
a lot of the commissions i'd make
anywhere from a few hundred dollars
to like a few thousand at the moment the
most i mean if i made like three four
grand on
like i was that was a ton so most of
these agents would never do that because
it's a lot of work it's like
imagine selling a house except you're
renting and you get
120th of the commission yeah so no
agents would bother with it but
for me when i was like 18 19 i would
love it
like because it didn't matter to me i
just wanted to get the leases but that
expanded and then what i found cool was
that
i would always post like 10 to 20 leases
up on craigslist at any given point so
if you're looking for
anything and like really from santa
monica to west hollywood you would see
one of my leases if you're looking
between five and fifteen thousand a
month
and landlords started calling me hey we
see you have all the leases here like
you're the leasing expert meanwhile i'm
like some 22 year old yeah we see
you're the leasing expert uh you know i
have my house over here would you
consider uh putting it up for lease
i'm like absolutely yeah and so i
started growing that business from just
representing landlords
now the funny thing is a lot of those
landlords uh
i don't think i had a situation where i
represented a landlord that
eventually sold so it didn't work the
other way around
but it was great for meeting tenant like
tenants would buy something landlords
would just perpetually be a landlord
like they had no intention of selling so
i never was able to
to get the reverse of that but tenants
would consistently want to move on did
you learn the strategy from anybody or
did you just come up with this
uh strategy by yourself yeah when i
first started
uh i was working in an office with this
guy frank i don't frank's not watching
this but uh
what's up frank what's up frank frank
was the one who gave me the idea for
craigslist
okay uh because he was posting some
leases on craigslist
so that sparked the idea that's like
wait we should we should post on
craigslist
um and also the guy was working with uh
was was coaching frank and
together between the two of them they've
identified that like hey craigslist is a
good place to post up leases
but then i took it to like like imagine
just like posting videos on youtube just
like on the surface it's good to post
videos on youtube
but then i took it from the standpoint
of like how could i up these clicks so i
did the same thing like i'm doing on
youtube it's really fun
but like craigslist would show the
thumbnail picture so i'd pick
one picture to be my thumbnail picture
and then i would work on the titles i
realized that all caps titles
do the best and then i identified that
long titles stand out because i would
literally sit there
and just scroll and be like what catches
my attention and
i'd stop and i'd be like why did that
catch my attention and
so when you look at not the gallery view
but like the list view
you see all the titles around the same
and just one like really long
that would be mine like a really long
title and then i
i on the the no and no one was doing
this for
apartments but uh when you went to the
for sale section
you would see these people put like
stars on either side like these weird
like
brackets and stuff yep so i would put
those brackets on my
listings on apartments no one else is
doing that and i found this uh this is
when craigslist did html
they had a h like a track or a link
tracker that i signed up for
that tracks how many people are clicking
through on every single link
so i made a custom link on every single
one of my postings per property and i
had like 20 properties i had 20 links
and i would figure out how different
titles would affect the click-through
rate
and then i basically i came i identified
that back then this is like
10 years ago the longest titles did the
best
all caps with these big like bold black
brackets on either end
and i would always call it like you know
magnificent
dream estate in beverly hills
with pool or like you know i'd
definitely try to like sell it up
and then in the description and then
once they click through then i was like
how can i get their info and then that
was a totally different
set of uh of like figuring out how to
get them to call because i would notice
sometimes that like wait i'm getting a
lot of clicks on something
why aren't people calling or emailing
well funny enough
i realized that uh if i put call graham
stefan with coldwell banker
people wouldn't call me because he'd be
like oh he's a salesman
if i just put call graham stefan well
it's that people just weren't into it i
found
that people really liked call gram
no last names call gram phone number
email address oh wow people wouldn't
call they would email
but just knowing that there's a phone
number there for people to call
if they need to it makes them feel
comfortable to email me wow
yeah and then i had the whole ad
basically
where it was just and i figured it out
like the best
the most optimized ad was just uh
headline at the very top bedrooms
bathrooms
price brief description all the pictures
underneath and then below the pictures i
i just went crazy with keywords like one
two three four five
every city in los angeles was listed
there
yeah uh pool hardwood open floor plan
like any
anything you could think of yeah and
that did really well and i was probably
getting
uh 20 to 50 maybe emails a day
a day yeah it was crazy so it got to a
point where
i would actually stop posting on
craigslist
yeah because i couldn't handle it all so
there was a point there where i'd only
post on craigslist when i needed
business
it was that good yes it was that good it
was incredible
so jeremy if you're starting over today
how would you
build up a portfolio oh today
so the way i did it back in the day was
was value stocks first
because that's the easiest to really
understand and uh figure out the
valuations to
so i mean today i would probably be more
inclined to do growth stocks but
the issue is i didn't have anybody to
teach me
i had no mentor i had nobody to hold my
hand and be like this is the way you
look at a growth stalker how to value
youtube back when i
you know i was lucky if i could find
some warren buffett clips but he's not
going in detail in those clips like
and warren buffett is not also really
not a growth investor he's a value
investor so
um i had really nobody to learn from so
it's hard but nowadays i feel like
there's so much good information out
there i would have
an idea of how to value growth stocks
probably in the first year
maybe not to a super high level but to a
high enough level to where i'd feel
comfortable
because i didn't really start touching
growth stocks until i'd been in the
market for several several years
so i think if i started today
i really focus around kind of what i do
a combination of dividend stocks value
stocks and growth stocks
and building out a portfolio uh over the
course of the first year or two that's
really centered around those stocks
um which in my first years it was really
just value
um so i you know let's say i had
hypothetically ten thousand dollars
i would probably focus on buying
two growth stocks uh probably
uh two value stocks and then one
dividend stock
something like that and um just trying
to find the ones that are the best deals
out there and things like that how do
you look for those stocks
well i mean uh you you can you can find
them many ways are you
in terms of how do you hear about a
stock or how do you get the the thought
process to look in this stock how do you
both hear about a song and then no it's
good to buy
do you check out every stock that you
hear about no there wouldn't be enough
time in the day for that
especially nowadays with you know
youtube comments uh
stock hub like the private discord chat
no there's no way
um i'm trying to look for or i'm trying
to hear about a stock that
the business model i hear something
about the business model that's
intriguing to me
that's the main thing i'm looking for if
i hear about a stock in the business
model sounds somewhat intriguing
also i'm like let me at least start
looking into that so all might go to
i don't know yahoo finance or whatever
and just look at the profile of the
company
oh you know it gives a kind of you know
a paragraph of what the company does
and i can start doing a little work from
there then kind of looking at some of
the financials income statement balance
sheet
i can look at some of the the valuation
numbers around it forward p
trailing 12-month pe things like that
and i started to get an understanding of
like do i really want to dive into this
company or is it i don't know
and so if it seems intriguing enough if
i do that
10 15 minutes of research and it seems
really really intriguing still
then then i'll dive into the 10ks
the 10 qs which are reports that are
available on companies investor
relations pages
like if you want to look into uh apple
you type in apple investor relations
boom
you can get all the information you
could ever imagine in terms of apple
right
and i'll go down that rabbit hole list
of conference calls and then
re-look at valuations think about future
growth rates and kind of make judgments
from there
but um i mean nowadays oh my gosh i get
stocks fed from so many different places
um i mean i hate to give it a shout out
in the video but 75
plus my stock picks come from my private
stock group and that's no lie i'm not
just fabricating that
uh 75 plus on my stock picks come from
in there because
these people have been trained under me
essentially on what i look for in stocks
for some of these folks for years i've
been following my content
and we have this like brain trust of
people that just look into stocks all
day
and then like well what do you guys
think about this talk i'm thinking about
buying this and they'll post like a
bullish case and i'm like nah nah
nah nah ooh they got something here
tattooed chef
that came from the private stock group
corsair gaming came from the private
stock group every single
stock pretty much i can think of in the
recent past
year actually the spark the initial idea
came from the private discord chat
and then from there essentially i'll
make my own judgments i'll look into the
company research and stuff and a lot of
the stocks
they're just like nah no not interested
not a good stock or it's just not the
stock for me
so it's kind of about sifting through
that it's almost like
you know you ever seen a a guy on the
beach and you must have you know as a
kid or whatever you know
a guy on the beach with oh yeah the
metal detector metal detector yeah
that's how i feel like sometimes you
know in the discord chat i'm like you
know trying to sift through all this
stuff and then like there's that
one there and i'm like i just found the
rolex watch on the beach here
there we go baby somebody dropped their
rolex
so somebody dropped their 24 carat
necklace here we go and so
yeah that's what it's about it's about
sifting through and finding that
that real diamond in a rough or the
needle in the haystack or whatever you
want to call it so
that would be fun to go with a metal
detector down to santa monica beach
should you imagine i would love to do
this yeah
imagine you're like in some area and
like some guys like hey that's my area
this is this i do this every day in this
area
i bet that exists i bet people have
territories territories
yeah they just pull out a knife and be
like nope uh-uh
my beach i'm always interested about
people getting discouraged when they
first start investing and then they lose
money
like what how likely is someone to stop
investing for the rest of their life
if they try once and then the market has
a sell-off and then they lose money and
they pull out
yeah that usually happens if somebody
doesn't start with the right mentality
from the go
and uh yeah they'll buy a stock and then
it goes down 10
20 and they're like stock markets a scam
sell take my
2 000 loss and get out of this thing
right uh i think if you have the right
mentality from the jump
and you've been trained as a long-term
investor and to understand these things
over time
uh will pay off if you've done the right
research work and you know what you're
looking for
i think if you've been trained the right
way you stay with it and you'll stick
with it and you'll
uh buy the dip as they say especially if
it's a good company like that's usually
the best thing you can do right let's
say the market goes down
30 the next month super unrealistic but
let's say it happens what's the smartest
thing you do more than likely by the dip
because i can almost guarantee the
market's gonna be massively higher in 10
years than it is today right
so a lot of it comes down to being
trained with the right mentality
uh from the jump in understanding and uh
you know learning from folks
you know that's why i think it's so
great on youtube nowadays that we have
this bunch to educate folks um you know
on financial matters and you know why
why it doesn't make sense to panic sell
out of stocks in a stock market crash
and stuff like that
because so many people were taught the
wrong things
like they think oh it's if you're in a
recession sell your stocks
no if you're in a recession that means
the stock market likely already crashed
you need to buy every stock
in sight because i highly doubt we're
going to stay in that recession forever
right
um you know and so a lot of it comes
down to having the right mentality
long-term mindset and uh talking you
know we were talking about the real
estate earlier
right graham had a long-term mindset and
so you you had the right mindset to
succeed there if you
if you were just thinking about landing
the the next
uh orlando bloom deal you would have
gotten anywhere right you would have
been out of business and i'm sure some
realtors try that and then they don't
make any business and they're like this
is a scam i'm out of this it's too hard
and same thing with stock market you've
got to have that long-term mentality
and um avoid distractions that's the
biggest thing i would say
so because yeah people people fall under
those traps
what would your advice be if somebody
wants to make like a hundred bucks a day
in the market
what would you tell those people i would
tell those people not to focus on 100
a day focus on what you're doing over
the course of that year
focus on like what you're doing over the
next three years five years
um this whole let's make 100 a day 200 a
day
400 a day whatever it is attractive
it is no doubt no doubt when people hear
that they're very attracted by that
right
and so they're thinking like oh i can
quit my job because i make 150
a day from my job i can make 150 a day
from the stock market bubba
usually extremely unrealistic you're not
usually going to do that
this year i'll probably make
i don't know maybe i'll make a half
million dollars to a million dollars
from stocks from like stocks i sell
right
you know i don't know what that equates
to on a daily basis but what i do know
is i didn't get there by focusing on how
much i make per day
that's not the way this goes you got to
focus over the long term you can't focus
on
the 100 the 500 a day don't get in don't
get sucked into that
if you if you you're gonna end up going
down the day trading route
that's what's going to end up happening
because also you're thinking well i've
got to make money today
i'd make 100 bucks today well let me
swing trade let me day trade and also
next thing you know
you're not even investing now you're
just trading around stocks and you
you're getting more into gambling
activities
you're not making business decisions
whenever i make an investment of stock i
say i'm making a business decision
i'm thinking about that company over
years kind of like you would think about
buying a
uh or getting a i don't know a
chick-fil-a franchise or a mcdonald's
franchise right
you wouldn't be thinking about oh
tomorrow i'm going to make this much
from this
chick-fil-a or this mcdonald's no you're
thinking about like i'm going to make
this over the
coming years the restaurant if it does
this sales volume i may be able to sell
it to somebody else for this that's the
way you're thinking right
and um and so yeah it's a different
mentality it's a longer term outlook
it's longer term focus
and uh yeah i wouldn't get caught up
into the daily numbers
so it's fun it makes it attractive
thumbnail or title on youtube but man
it's just not the way to go what are
some stocks that you like
right now besides tattoos yeah besides
besides the chef corsair gaming i've
been talking about that one a lot so
yeah why aren't they going up
so with that one um i mean it's trading
ridiculously cheap
i bought that to make a hundred bucks a
day where is my hundred dollars a day i
don't
see it oh man you might make 100k over
time but yeah i know when
it comes to corsair uh there's an eagle
fund that's selling out private equity
companies so
that is uh uh i think their eagle fund
there they're called
so essentially that that puts a big
seller in the market they they made a
lot of money on that investment they
want to put the money somewhere else
so it kind of puts an overhang seller in
the market you don't know when they're
done selling you don't know
when they're selling you just know that
they're selling the market right
on top of that you got fear about world
opening back up
gamers and streamers i don't know aren't
going to care about gaming and streaming
and
to that i say have you ever met a gamer
or a streamer like
these people don't care if the world's
open and they're gaming and streaming
man
it doesn't matter to them like come on
and um
and so that's going on but the the great
the great opportunity when it comes to
stocks is the fact that usually
you get months to buy into a position
sometimes even a year or two
depending upon the stock 2020 messed up
everybody's
mentality because stocks went up so fast
coming out for the crash right and so
people think like that's normal like oh
stocks go boom
no usually you get three six sometimes
even nine to 12 months
to really truly build out a position in
something like a corsair gaming
or tattoo chef or whatever stock it is
before it starts going on a run
we call it right and uh that's usually
normal but
we got in such a hot market last year
that everybody thinks like
if the stock didn't make money this
month it sucks it's a bad stock and it's
like that's just not the way the stock
market works and you're kind of getting
into a short-term mentality
so you know i look for for opportunity
there um
and i mean there's some other stocks
that are deficient values know that
we've talked about before like the
planet
um and some of those but those are
really long-term investments like those
i'm thinking about many years out
like if i'm thinking about the plan 13
as an investment i'm thinking about
when they have 10 super stores right now
they have two
but they're going to get to 10 in my
opinion within the next five years so
i'm thinking about
you know years out and um so yeah those
are those are some of the stocks come to
mind when
when stock comes to mind wba stock comes
to mind
wins us very solid in my opinion value
stock
travel coming back wba is very solid
dividend stock
so uh right there i think i gave some
some gross stocks some values and some
dividends
so yeah so how many stocks do you own
probably about 20 if you added up all
the different stocks in all my accounts
probably about 20. in the public account
i own 13. i only know that because i
counted them up today literally
on 13 accounts that account has 1.6 mil
i think in it and um but if you added up
all the stocks in different accounts
about 20 stocks
so um you know when it comes to
diversification i don't like to over
diversify
but i don't like to under diversify
either i feel like i'm appropriately
priced for for what i have you know the
smaller amount of money
in my opinion the less stock somebody
should have the more money you have the
more stocks you should have
so and i'm still in it to win it so i'm
not trying to just uh getting 500 stocks
like like snp500
what what are some of the other
businesses that you have let's talk
about the app
by the way now is that now is the time
where we could finally talk about the
elusive app the hungry bullet you could
now download on the app store that we've
been working on yes the hungry
yeah and uh yeah so that that's exciting
so
you know we had the idea around starting
a newsletter an email newsletter
and uh we were talking about that idea
and basically starting a business
focused newsletter
that didn't have any biases
didn't come across as anything
politically related and really stuck to
business related subjects because what i
found is
a lot of business newsletters go
way off subject and they start talking
about politics
they start talking about more pop
culture type things and it's like
like you know let's talk about business
you know what i mean like if it's not in
relation to like
what's going on in the markets stock
market real estate market
uh you know business in general like you
know if i'm signed up to a business
letter i want business right
and so that's where i started then we
were like well what if we built out an
app team
uh an in-house app team and did this the
the right way and so i was like well
uh i could fund that and we ended up
doing it and then
just kept adding on features like now
you can track your stocks so you can add
your whole portfolio in there so if you
got 5 10 20 stocks whatever you can
track them all in there
and then it was like what if we could
listen to a conference call directly in
the app
so if you you want to listen to tattoo
chef's conference call you type in ttcf
or if it's on your thing already saved
you just type you know you hit it
earnings call boom it plays for your
rate there you can
rewind it 15 seconds you know fast
forward and
instead of having to go their investor
relations page and go through all these
different things and then try to find it
sometimes that takes five minutes just
to find a day in conference call
and play it and you have to enter in all
your information and so then we got to
talking about what if we could set up an
account
and comment kind of like you can on
youtube right what if you want to make
comments to on
on the newsletter so we added that
feature and then we have a forum feature
coming down the road and other features
coming down the road
so it's exciting man it's very costly
to uh start up a company from scratch
like this in the software space in
in app development team and things like
that no doubt
very costly it is a big risk i'm hoping
you know people love it and it's a big
it's a big success but uh but yeah it's
been it's been fun it but it is
sometimes stressful because i'm looking
at it
and i'm plowing a ton of money into that
and
we might never make money from it you
never really know you know what i mean
like you never know how these things
will work out when it's something you've
never done before yeah
but um i've learned a lot from it and uh
i'm really i'm really proud of the
initial product and i know we're just
gonna continue to make it better and
better over the future years so
yeah so how about this um because i'm a
part of it too
uh we'll put the link to it down below
in the description
download it and try it out let us know
what you think
and uh we should we should probably set
something up for like comments or like
uh or suggestions so
try it out and then send us your
suggestions so you'll be like you'll be
like
our kind of helpers on this we just uh
launched a really exciting feature
so inside the newsletter part now so if
you click on a newsletter article
now there's a tab at the bottom big
green thing that says
feedback you click on that button you
could type in whatever you want
so uh yeah so if you have any feedback
suggestions uh
positive things whatever and if you
really love the app if you don't mind
leaving us a review on google play store
or ios that would mean so much to us
because we've been working on that thing
for months
yeah so um but yeah i'm excited we're
just going to make that thing better and
better over time and uh
yeah who knows where it is in a few
years from now so i really want to know
how much money uh
you know jeremy's bringing in just like
in general that wow that's not how much
money you know what bringing it
technically you've never really revealed
how much
money you've uh you make yeah
and and net worth yeah never really
revealed that
yeah you don't have to yeah but uh
okay uh net worth
between 10 and 20. i will not gonna tell
you this number
now yes are we counting like the youtube
channel and like the value of the are we
adding in
oh i'm adding zero for the app because
that's nothing right
now um i'm adding in uh almost
nothing for youtube channels that would
just be other stuff
um including i have a lot in just stocks
like
like a really large number just in
stocks i have
several properties now i have three
properties all of them have
uh at least a quarter million in equity
for those properties at least um
including
a couple that have between 300 and 400
um i have a you know i have multiple
positions alone in the stock market that
are seven figures
so you know and then uh you know there's
got to be something to like business and
stuff like that so
yeah i i would say i make millions and
my my net worth is between 10 and 20.
and how how much you have invested in
the stock market just just in stocks can
we
i can't disclose that either but it's a
it's a really large number
so so let's see this there's it's
bigger than you could there's 1.6 mill
in the public in the public account yes
the private account is
is substantially bigger than that
because that is the account
i've had literally since yeah the
beginning of time
are you the only one who gets to see the
private account yes not a soul
including my own wife no no she doesn't
know my
wife does not know what i have in the
private can i see it can i see it i can
just get my reaction no one will ever
see it no
it's it's the one it's one of the very
few things that i have as
like a private map does your does your
wife want to know no
she doesn't care she's really uh my
wife's probably one of the
least money interested individuals i
know and maybe that's why our
relationship works pretty good
but uh but yeah she she no what if your
son comes up to you daddy daddy how am i
pleased
why is it so secret why it's fun it's
fun
it has you guys intrigued what drives us
crazy yeah i don't know
i want to know what i'm saying
let me ask you guys just to clear the
confusion is there a
private account for your members only
and is there a
public private account yeah so the
public account is for the private stock
group
so that's why i call the public account
so the private stock group's gotten to
see every single trade executed in the
history of that account alex
the private account is literally
completely private
completely private like sometimes i'll
disclose a position why
i just like it what brokerage is it uh
well it's got to be fidelity because
because
you're all of your accounts now somebody
have fidelity's gonna go in there and
hack in and be like i gotta i gotta see
this account
let me ask you guys how much in stocks
do you think i have in the private
account what would be your
guess uh the three of you might get and
my guess would probably be
six to eight six to eight okay five five
alex graham's cheating because he can't
give a range um
but i'm going well seven now let's say
seven yeah i'm gonna
actually go a little bit higher than
graham and say seven
point eight seven point eight
how about who's the closest from all of
us
who's the closest
who's the closest oh yeah we could we
could save the closest
because that doesn't reveal it
it'd be graham graham would be the
closest
anyways yeah it's a pretty large number
but i'm broke now because i'm funding
two startups simultaneously one i can't
talk about
and obviously the hungry bull so can you
say what your overhead is
like your monthly overhaush my monthly
overhead's disgusting
disgusting you hire everything you
literally employees you have
hired you have like 80 employees don't
you it's it's a it's a large number of
workers let's just call it that
so um it's six figures every two weeks
yeah six figures every two weeks it's
it's it's quite a substantial number
so then can you answer the other part of
alex's question how much are you making
uh making i actually don't know that
number it's it's millions of dollars
a year um last year
last year let's see uh so last year
i paid in almost a million dollars in
taxes so you could run numbers backwards
on that on what i'm actually making
five mil four mil yeah no it depends on
what the expenses are we're talking next
we're talking net then you'd be paying
forty percent in tax
plus a few other like little times i
think between
different businesses stock sales
everything that you could possibly count
up probably
four to five top line so um
yeah but pre-expenses are gross no that
that's just revenue that's just top line
something around there so but um but
yeah i
you know at the end of the day what i
found is
people people matter people is what's
really going to grow you
and if you have really good people
you're going to figure out ways to to
help you grow
bigger and bigger when it comes to
businesses and um
and you know it's about hiring the right
people and you know folks that are gonna
do a great job eight players but
what i found is usually if you hire
somebody and they're truly great
they're going to bring 3x 4x more to the
table than they take
so if you you hire somebody to pay them
i don't know let's say 100k a year
they're truly great they're going to
bring you 300 to 400 of true value
to whatever you're trying to do and so
that's the way i look at it and whenever
we think about business expenses
business costs
the last thing i think about is people
i'll think about every
service and we use in this software do
we really need this every other expense
before i think about people and cutting
salaries and i learned that at quick
trip
quick trip paid probably double or
triple what
all other gas stations paid for this
this same workers
but people at quick trip you know
they're just there's a different bunch
you're getting a different you know
caliber of people and they're going to
bring you way more business than
than they take because they have great
customer service skills and those sorts
of things right so that's the way i
think about it
and uh i appreciate everybody that's
supported along the way because if it
wasn't for that we wouldn't be here and
i appreciate it for the stock market
because it certainly wouldn't beer if it
wasn't for the stock market man
that's for dang sure so um but yeah
it's uh it's a big number man in terms
of the expenses
you should review jack's robin hood
account we should hear what this is
as a iced coffee our uh channel clips
if i butchered that iced coffee our
clips channel exclusive so it's only
going to be available on the link down
below in the description
we're trying to boost up the clips
channel a little bit so this is only
going to be
available there whoa that's not
really i just love that you're our
neighbor now because i'll like leave the
house
and i'll be i'll see you like walking up
the street with your shirt off
oh wow neighbor hello neighbor hello
how's it going today yeah jack between
this podcast and fadea's podcast
it just sounds like you like to see guys
with their shirt off
no i'm just saying you had your shirt
off that one time you remembered vividly
don't you
i just thought it was like one time
without the shirt on no i just thought
it was funny that he was walking on the
street with a shirt what's funny about
it
that he's what that it's a million
dollar neighborhood and
some guy's walking walking up the street
with his shirt off yeah that's something
you you had your wait did you have you
headed off right anyways i like the fact
that you're a neighbor yeah
and uh it's it's great like going out
and just seeing you
that's what i look forward to every day
all right so jeremy thank you so much
for coming on for fourth
time all the way over yeah thank you it
was a far walk
through the desert sands of las vegas
and i appreciate it guys this was fun as
well
so really appreciate it with that said
guys thank you so much for watching i
really appreciate it make sure to hit
the like button
subscribe button get the get the hungry
ball app down below in the description
where you can also get your free stock
we'll link to your information down
below as well
thank you again for watching and until
next time
well holy